We made more than one video about how you can create a
multilingual online store and multilingual websites
for companies and institutions. Many of you
told us that you told us that you can profit from
this topic. How can we profit from the
idea of ​​creating websites or the idea that we create
personal websites and benefit from them financially? Some
questions.  What came to us and what we will answer
today. The first question: Is it possible to buy
one hosting and put more than one website on it? Ok,
how do we buy from the site that you recommended? Because the format has completely changed from before. If we bought one hosting and put more than one website on it, would
each customer be one of the customers that bought it?  They will have
the hosting. They will have their own control panel. I
can send them an email as I explained before. The
name of the person. Give the name of the company. Dot.com.
How can I do the protection protocol that is for
all the sites in the hosting? If
I created my own personal website, can I
benefit from this website?  Financially, for example, in one of
the ways, and finally, how can I contact
customer service if I have any problem with
the site so that they can help me? Let’s get started.
Peace be upon you. This is Omar Mohsen from our channel. Let’s
go to the first question: Is it possible to buy
one hosting and have more than one website on it? Yes, you can
do it.  This is how we explained one of the hosting
sites. The possibility of adding more than one
website to the hosts. The
first step you take is to buy the hosting and the domain.
If you do not know the difference between them, we would have explained it in the
previous video. The second step is to buy an
additional domain to put it on the site you are the first
hosting you purchased.  You can buy
or you can transfer the domain from another hosting so that
it is all available to you in one place, and more
than one site in one hosting. The third step is that if
this site is not ready, you can download it, for example,
and create the site on it or an online store
on it. Come, let us go to my work and see how to start first.
Step by step, we will go to describe the video by
clicking on More and opening the first link that
introduces us to the Hostinger site. We will buy through the
site. We will notice that the site opens in this way. We will go down and see
what plans are available.
In my episode, I will choose the most common plan. We
will notice here that in detail, I add up to 100 sites
and the number  The total number of visits to these sites is a date,
and in addition to the other features that we talked
about before, we will go to Add to Cart and choose our duration.
The longer it is, the
lower its cost. In my case, I will choose
12 months and go down and enter my data. If
I had a membership before, I will add it. If I do not have it, I will
register.  For example, I can register with it.
I will log in using the email that I used to use
with you before. After we log in, he will start asking me what I want to
pay through. I have a Visa and
America. This is simple. Any direct debit housing card or credit card will be issued by the bank. If you have any bank, it will be.  It is present on the logo of a
Visa or MasterCard. This bank is
internationally accepted and accepts the payment process, but you need to
make sure that the bank confirms that your visa is activated
on the Internet. Of course, the site is very secure and we
buy from it periodically, so we will go down after that and we
will see the total plan and its
annual cost, and this includes the domain name.  Your website is
hosted. Of course, if you have more than
one website, you can add other domain names.
We will go to the coupon code and enter the code
in order to get an additional account. We will notice that the price is
47. He told me forty-four, and we put the information
on our card, the first name, the numbers on the face of the
card, like this.  You do not see
this, the
expiration date is the month, the year, and the
three numbers on the back of the card. We
send the payment that I have. In my case, I have it.
I will pay directly via PayPal. Click here and pay directly with this. We have purchased the domain and the
main hosting for your site. We will complete the
rest of the steps according to what appears before us. Of course,
differences may vary.  It is simple with the time
you are going to buy the site, but the result is the same.
You are here. He asks you why you are creating the site. We can
tell him, “We don’t want any details.” He tells you, “You are
publishing a new site or transferring.” I will create an
empty site so we can start with some explanation. He
asks you the first thing. “You have potential.”  You get a
free domain that you want. We click on Select
to choose our domain name. We choose
what the site will be. It will be Dot.com, for example, and we write
here the name of the site, but I will choose Omar, for
example, the name of the site. Dot.com, and write. Click on
Search. You will be sure that the site is available. If it is not
available, you will start changing it.  Do not choose the name that
is available.
If anyone enters Omar, he will find my
site. Click on Follow. It tells me
where your server is. Okay. Finish the settings.
Here it appears for me. We enter our data. We enter the
first and last names. Girls. Of course, they must be
correct in order to register a domain with them. Of course, this data is
possible.  You get it from Google, write the postal code for
Cairo and Alexandria, and it also gives you numbers if
you do not know this data. After that, click
on Finish Registration. This is how you created the
domain or your main website. It is currently
downloading the method for creating the website. My website is now ready. I can
now display my website
if you click.  Here it shows me the site that
I bought. It
may be a little late to open it, so don’t worry until it opens. We will notice this
point. We will also solve it. We will come back again. We will go to To
go to our control panel, it is
very beautiful. This is my main control panel.
Of course, the language is Arabic. We can change it at any time
from here and choose the language.  We want it. If we
want English or another language, we have finished the first
step, which is that we bought the hosting and the domain. What remains is that
we want to add an additional site. We will start adding an additional site. How can we go
and start reviewing for us here? It will show us
the sites that I have. I am in the same situation as mine.
Here it was.  I had a website before on the same
hosting called Do
you remember that we made it in one of the videos and now I have Omar Noology, so now I
have two websites on one hosting and I can
provide at any time. Ok, I will provide it. How do I go to domains and click on Get a
new domain from here or  I am transferring a domain
from another friend and we can explain this also in a
separate video. If you would like to know how I can
transfer the domain to my add-on and click on it to
get a new domain and write the name of the site
I want to write, for example, Afnan and do a search.
Now I will leave it open. I will not choose
automatic. It will start browsing for me.
I started buying this domain
for ten dollars a year. So if
I bought my hosting, but I will buy the
domain at a separate price. If this is a name, you buy it from a
dealer annually, or I can choose a name that
has a cheap price called Afnan Online.
For example, I will take this site and click on buy.
This is the price.  It has one dollar point. 17.
If I buy this domain, what does it include for protecting your
data? Ok, I will click on complete payment. I
will notice that it has been added
to my settings. We will click on this settings entry in order to register my data on the site. It is necessary, of course, for any site you
buy to have its data registered and completing the registration is the
next step.  This will tell me that I registered
this domain. Go to your email and activate
this site so that it remains linked to your name. We will go to
our email to
activate the domain. We will notice that this email belongs to Afnan and click on activation from here so that the site is registered
in our name. This is how the site registers. We will close the rest of this page.
If  This site, Dim Dot Online movies,
is still registered with me, and here it recommends me, telling me
if I want to
go back again. We will notice
that my hosting has
one, two, and three sites. How can I differentiate between these
sites? We will go to hosting. We will notice that I
have a new age and an old site that we used to host.
Ok, if  I want to add the site that
I recently added. How will we go about adding a
site? You will ask me. Do you want to add any site? We want an empty site. What is the domain of
Addy Afnan D Online that we have already
bought and click on select and finish
the settings? It creates a control panel for
this site on  Coincidence with me and the spirit of
people, we close all these pages. That's it. It's
very nice. This site remains among
the sites I have. If we go to host it
again, we will notice, O D Afnan, this is Omar Wadi. The
other site is
beautiful. This is beautiful. Of course, the difference between
this hosting and the one above is that I was  I bought a
hosting before to show you, and I have
another hosting, but here we are explaining one hosting that
can have more than one website.
Thus, we answered the question: How
do we create more than one website on one hosting? We come to the second question: How can we work on any websites? This is a quick explanation,
so also the method if  I disagree with you. I
want to download a WordPress site on this site. I will click
on manage, and after that I
will go to the automatic installer. Of course, we will try to explain it a little quickly
so that those who do not know how to think of the method. I will go
to I want to download a regular site or a
commercial site in, for example, a store. Here I will put a regular site
and choose  What will the address name of my site be, and what is its
password? Enter this site
and click Next. Here it asks me: Do you want
its language to be the primary? If you want it to be
Arabic, leave it from here, and so on, and start installing
like this. It simply downloads Word to this site, and
after that, the explanations have not changed if we are still going.
This is in the explanation of adding the
style to modify it. We explained it
in our videos. Our site
is now ready. We can see it now or within
five days. I mean, if the site is not opened at all
times, do not be sad. Of course, the domain is still being
prepared, and this is how we know how it is possible for a
single coincidence to be added.  It has more than the site and each
site you control, add to, modify it,
and so on.
We learned how we can add WordPress to one of
the sites, because of the many questions that came to me: How do we
add WordPress? We come to the third question:
Is it possible for each site to have a separate control panel? The answer is
yes and no. The word “control panel” is
this.  This means that it may be the hosting control panel
for all sites, or it may be your control panel in
which we modify the site. Other than that,
if you are asking the first question, then the hosting is one host, but if you
share the password with
someone, then he can see all the sites you have,
but if you give him the password from the board  The
WordPress control that we are still working on has a little
name and the password is like that, no problem. Any of
your clients can take a log on the control panel, but
if you want to share with them the control panel for the
site’s files in something called FTPD, you
can simply get it and give it if you want in the
Uber programmer.  You can view the FTP data
in order to get data
and access the accounts. It
is a way to access it in order to see the
files on the site, like a flash drive. This is how
you access the files in it. This is the data of the site that I am opening now, it is called Afnan
Deem Online. This is the main data, and this is the
password you can request.  From you, if you
deal with and
write the password and share it with the person,
and of course you can navigate from the sites simply
through from here and choose the site you want,
Omar Nology, or the other site, which is
Afnan, of course, let us not mix between them
here. I am open to Omar, if you enter the control panel and the
installer is automatic.  Through it, we will be able to add a
separate add to the Omar Noji website from the other website
that we created. The next question is:
Can I create an email for each of these companies
? Yes, you can do it. The first step is that we will choose the site
that we want to create an email on, for example,
Omar. Quickly click on the administration.
After that, we will notice on the left in  E-mail
We click on E-mail Accounts
and we will notice that here I also browse. I have the names and
sites. Of course, in a shortcut, we will get them through the
place above here and choose. What do we
want to send an e-mail to? I want, for example,
to Omar and choose one of our administrations. Notice that he has
two things, one for one free money. Me.  I
will choose the free one. It will give me one gigabyte of space. I will be able to
transfer emails and so on. I will
choose it. From here, I will create an email account. We will choose the email
name, for example, the
email address. If the password is, we will create it. And, frankly, of
course, a video. Before that, how can you
transfer all the content of this email to
Gmail so that you can reply and receive emails?  Gmail,
which is originally priced at five dollars a month,
which is Gmail
through this service, you can do it for free
only if you have hosting.
We also explained it in the video above, but we also
created an email on this domain. Yes, of course, we can choose
the email or choose any other site.
Afnan and we also send an email to Afnan.
If you notice the same steps from here, it is okay, even if the
company is, of course, large in size and wants to send
emails to Google, for example, or emails to
Microsoft. The matter is simple. You also go to the
same control panel of the email accounts
and go to the DNS settings,
and from here you take the motherboard.  MX and you
start modifying
what will come to you from G Suite or Microsoft. If you
go and buy an email from Google or
Microsoft, they will give
you MX Record, which you will put in this email. Therefore, I
tried the idea of ​​these emails from this site, and
it manages the issue, of course, for two months. This is, of course, if you are a
large company or  You have a large number of
employees. This question is Galaxy, so we come to the
next question: How can I manage the
site on all the sites I have in my hosting? We go
to the site where we want to activate the feature. We go to the website. We
choose, for example, Afnan, who is still
new, to manage the site in order to activate the H.T.
PS on this site. If we notice that the lock is not
there, we will go to Advanced and choose and click on
Install. Simply put, you will find that it activates
SSL on the site
as well. Because it has not yet created a domain, it will not be useful to activate SSD. This will
take us to the question: How can we contact
customer service?  If I have any problem, we will simply go
down to the circle at the end of the screen,
click on it, and we will notice that from here it is possible to go
down and work or communicate with customer service. It will appear for
you. I will go
here and write
the feature of course in the topic that they speak
in Arabic. The topic is easy and it will tell you
what the problem is.  What you have, click on it.
In my case, I really have a problem with the series, so
click here.
Here it selects compulsory questions. I want to know the
topic or wait for the live specialist. Of course, this is a
direct response from them. I want Arabic and English. We wait
a while. If they have pressure in customer service,
or we write our own question. Please, I need
activation and you will find it.  After that, they will do the service for you
directly. You can say from my website
that it is not working. You want to turn it on for me if there is a problem.
Thus, you will find them helping you. They will contact you as
soon as possible. We will come to the last question. How if I have a
personal website that I can profit from. Of course, there are many ways
to profit from personal websites if you have them.
A store through which you sell products. If you have,
for example, a service that you promote yourself and you can benefit
from, or the most common method is that
you add a code belonging to Google AdSense through which
advertisements will be displayed on your site, and any number of
people who see these advertisements or interact with them
by clicking on them, you will receive a return.
This method is simple. Google will be an intermediary
between you and the company. I am a company and I want to make
advertisements on different sites. We go to Google
first. I want to buy a service from you. I make an advertisement, and in
exchange for this, I will certainly pay money. Google takes
money from the advertiser and distributes these ads on the
site. My hand is to them.  He takes a percentage. This is an idea
as simple as Google Adsense. Of course, there are requirements
for your site to be acceptable to Google
AdSense if he puts your code. We can explain
this topic in a separate video, but if they search for a
way to accept or add two Google AdSense accounts or
submit to Google, you will find many videos.  It is very
available on the Internet. This was
simply today's video. Thank you for listening. I
apologize if it is long for you. I tried to summarize the
topic. These questions came to me a lot. I will see you
well in a new video.
Peace be upon you.